You've become a bridegroom or something, so
if you proceed like an idiot, you'll say you'll end up with two things, so you're going to end up building a
company
Damn, my dad nagging me,
bowing my head
I don't understand the most
, so I'm saying I'm glad
I didn't run away
[Music]
Don't run away from me
If you have anything you want to say, say it It's
annoying as usual
[Music] It's
Miori Tell me to leave it to you
[music]
Leave it to me I
can't stay by your side all the time Do
n't lose in the duel I won't
lose I'll
definitely
add biode to tomatoes
Clean up twice a week Send me
emails three times a day
Mioline is
crying Don't look at
me But you can't believe what I say
[Music] I
can't believe